all right what's going on everybody
it is our monthly patreon exclusive
livestream we're changing it up this
month so what we've always been doing
here with patreon is I do this video
this livestream where I take questions
from patrons and we only share the video
with patreon people but I realized last
month that when we were doing this that
it's like I think more of you want more
people to be able to hear the questions
you're asking and hear my answers so I
asked everybody basically I was like
look how about we let only patreon
members submit the questions but we'll
post this video live to our YouTube feed
as we're doing right now and let
everybody hear the answers that way it
gets more people here and your questions
more people here in my answers and
hopefully for some of you guys that
haven't joined us on patreon hopefully
you will join us so if you want to get a
question it to me first off it's
patreon.com slash rubin report and I
think it's the level 1 tier gets ya gets
you right in on on this and I've got a
trusty iPad here my guys are sending me
questions on the fly and we're gonna do
about an hour of Q&A totally uncensored
whatever you want to ask me I'm reading
them right here I haven't even looked at
them yet
I've been doing patreon Hangouts all day
long you know we for the higher tier
members we do small group chats we used
to do one-on-ones now we're doing them
in groups so I've been going all day
long I am wearing a hat which people
don't get to see me in a hat that often
but I haven't even showered today
because it's been a crazy freakin day of
patreon hangouts and just catching up on
life as you guys know I've been last 3
weeks on the road with Jordan Peterson
and we were in Denmark at Sweden and
Norway and UK and Ireland and I'm
definitely forgetting some other places
but we've been all over the place looks
like we just signed on for probably
another 30 shows in Europe in March and
April we got a whole bunch of stops in
Australia in February they're just great
energy behind what we're doing I'm so
enthused and psyched and I just I just
feel great at the moment and and I'm
looking forward to taking some questions
oh I'm just real quick let me pimp out
one one event I've been doing so I got
back from Helsinki
Oh Finland I forgot about Finland I got
back from Helsinki two days ago and then
I did stand up immediately that night in
Brea and then I did stand up last night
in Oxnard and both nights I brought two
members of the intellectual dark web I
always bring one so I do about an hour
of stand-up and then I bring the guests
from the IDW on I brought brought both
Weinstein brothers on stage and we're
just having a great time and it's
totally different so I hope if you guys
happen to be in a city where I'm doing
stand-up soon I hope you'll come check
it out I'll be in San Jose on November
28th at the San Jose improv and there
will be an IDW member with me and you
know I do stand-up but it's a lot of
crowd work and we do live Q&A and it's
really interactive and fun and I get the
crowd going at each other and it's a
politically diverse group of people and
it's and it's pretty cool and I'm
psyched about that and if you want to
just check out some more dates and tours
and other things that I'm doing you can
go to Dave Rubin dot-com slash events
and before I start I assume everybody
wants to say hi to Emma she's been
hanging out all day long in here she is
14 years old
how do you know the story about her
she's a rescuing from Hurricane Katrina
in New Orleans so she's lived in New
Orleans then she lived in New York for
about 10 years and now we've been living
in LA for a couple of years she's been
to the Grand Canyon she's been to the
White House the girl has lived through a
lot okay let's jump into questions
because that's what it's all about so we
will go right there when you coming back
to San Francisco
so I've done a couple events in San
Francisco well I will be in San Jose on
November 28th that's pretty close to San
Francisco so hopefully you can come
check it out I think we're gonna do some
more stuff in San Francisco and I just
need to spend a couple days there
because there's a lot going on on tech
side of things as you guys can imagine
these days with all the algorithm
craziness and and YouTube stuff and
Twitter shadow banning so I need to
spend some time in San Francisco so
maybe on the 29th I'll do like some sort
of public event there if I can figure
out a way to do it but 28th I'm in San
Jose so do come and check it out Dave
after listening to the IDW I can no
longer listen to conservative talk radio
it seems shallow just like the
mainstream media what have you done to
me I've done something good
my friend this is what it's all about
look what is the IDW trying to do as
Eric Weinstein said who I think is sort
of the he was the sort of architect of
this in some ways and I've been sort of
the main facilitator and we've got all
sorts of people that are part of it it's
like what what do we agree on mostly and
what we agree on mostly is that we're
allowed to think differently but we
agree on what a conversation is what a
respectful conversation amongst people
who have different thoughts are which is
why I can sit in my studio of my own
home across from ben shapiro when he'll
tell me that he wouldn't attend my
wedding anniversary and we can we can
agree to disagree on things and we can
agree that we still want to live in the
same society as each other
I think what we've done with the IDW is
we shattered some of the notions that
media and the political establishment
has has thrust on all of us about how we
should behave where everyone who
disagrees with us is evil and everyone
who disagrees with us is a bigot or a
limp tart or a racist or a homophobe all
of this stuff it's not real it's tearing
us apart it's making people crazy and I
can tell you guys I just met them the
last three weeks bouncing all over
Europe I spent the two months before
that bouncing all over the United States
we've done 70 plus shows together I
think you are gonna die it'll be well
over 100 by the time we're done and
people are good they're out there they
want to solve problems and one of the
coolest things is so you right now a
person watching this most likely you're
watching this alone right you're you're
watching either on your phone or you're
sitting at your laptop or your desktop
you're not listening to this right
because we're only live-streaming this
on YouTube we will I think we're gonna
put this up on the podcast feed probably
but this is a sort of solo operation
like maybe you're watching it on your
Smart TV maybe you're your husband or
your wife or your boyfriend or
girlfriend is there but it's a pretty
solo experience ingesting all of this
content you know you can walk around
listening to these podcasts and it's a
solo thing and what I'm what I'm really
loving right now about the Petersons
events and now do and stand up again is
that people are coming into these rooms
and they're looking around and you're
going holy cow you know for the standard
shows there's hundreds of other
people laughing about the same [ __ ] that
I'm laughing about at the Petersen shows
there's thousands of other people that
are as interested in ideas and getting
your life right before you fix the world
fix yourself and they're coming together
and they're realizing holy cow I'm not
alone and yes they disagree all the
people that come there disagree on all
sorts of things and I have people that
come up to me after the shows and you
know a lot of people of course say Dave
I'm sort of on the same political
journey as you I used to be a big lefty
but I'm a liberal and that has nothing
to do with the left anymore people come
to me and say I'm the libertarian and
I've been waiting for some good liberals
to join forces with some people say I'm
a conservative and I disagree with you
on some things but but you know I
support what you're doing and all that
so look if you can't listen to talk
radio anymore because of what we've done
here I think that's pretty good you know
I'm not putting down anybody and the
people can do what they want listen to
who they want to listen to but I think
we've offered up something a little more
and I'm really proud of that and I think
we're just at the beginning again so
it's pretty exciting okay let's see Dave
have you followed the leftist attacks on
Peter Bogosian related to his probe on
grievous studies I have first off I love
Pete Pete's been on the show twice and
if you haven't seen particularly the
second so the first interview that I did
with Pete it was the first time we met
and we did mostly a talk at hour-long
talk about atheism and Pete wrote a book
called a manual for creating atheist we
did that about three years ago I think
it was three years ago this month
actually might've been this week it was
right before Thanksgiving huh
and Pete was on again about a year ago
in this studio and we did we talked
about all sorts of stuff but what was
great I think the first twenty or thirty
minutes was about the nature of French
actually his father had just passed away
and you know our friendship sort of
blossomed because I tried to be there
for him during that time he's a really
good guy look these guys wrote Pete and
James Lindsay and Helen pluck Rose wrote
these these fake academic papers that
got accepted by peer-reviewed journals
and they just freakin flipped all of
these nonsensical all of these
nonsensical ways that these departments
figure out what's real and what's not
real right
their head I mean it's actually
incredible so anyway pepitas a
philosophy professor at Portland State
University and the school paper issued
this statement all anonymously signed by
professors and grad students about how
awful he is and it's like man you know
he's put his butt at his career and his
life on the line to fight for what he
believes in and you guys won't even put
your names to this paper to this
statement against him and it's like you
you're all cowards if you were on the
side of truth you would stand up and be
who you are but you won't and this guy
is doing good work because what he what
peak I think basically believes is that
that the gender studies and these type
of disciplines that aren't peer-reviewed
that don't that don't come from a place
of empirical evidence like say the stems
do Pete would say they are infecting
every part of academia and it's not just
people says it it's plenty of other
people Jordan peterson says it plenty of
other people in academia realize what is
happening and so I love Pete I backbeat
and I hope that what he's done will have
wider effects and will ripple for a long
time commented I do think they will what
do you think is the future of comedy can
it get back to being funny and not just
political watch the Adam Sandler Netflix
than recently even though I was not a
fan and I enjoyed it partly because the
songs were funny and weird and because
there was no political content so I
haven't seen that thing yet you know
when I was younger especially in college
I loved Sandler his comedy was
off-the-wall it wasn't political it was
completely ridiculous then he had like
five or six movies in a row though
absolutely horrendous
and then those Netflix movies have been
pretty awful the Sandy Wexler one was
sort of okay but some of the others are
just terrible that one with David Spade
where he's a secret agent ursine he it's
not even a movie they need another word
for it it's so bad that being said I
haven't seen this yet but but if he got
back to his off-the-wall roots where he
you know what's happening and this is
what your questions about it's like
what's happening right now is that these
comedians have become the same type of
hectoring preaching blowhards that
they're supposed to be making fun of so
imagine if George Carlin who I think is
the greatest stand-up and
and the most prolific stand-up comic of
all time if he was alive today now first
off he'd be getting booed off college
campuses because he'd be an old white
guy defending the patriarchy and it's so
stupid right this is a guy who fought
the power his entire life but what would
he be doing he would be using comedy to
say what he wants to say but if you go
online now and you see what a lot of
really famous far more famous than me
comics are doing they're just yelling
and preaching and they're all they're
all progressive activists and Democratic
party members and all that stuff and
they're not funny anymore I mean the
amount of people who I used to like
comedic Lee who now it like make me kind
of nauseous is sick but that's actually
why I'm doing stand-up again and we did
great show in Oxnard last night we did a
great show and brand as I said I'm doing
something that's like more of like a
crazy road show slash Town Hall slash
interview slash Phil Donahue slash Jerry
Springer Show than anything else and I'm
treating my audience with respect we're
doing some politically incorrect stuff I
hope people aren't recording all of this
stuff because what what happens in a
comedy club is kind of sacred and a lot
of comics by the way now the big the big
time comics like Rogan and Chapelle who
both are spectacular comedians they
don't even let people bring their phones
you have to give up your phone you put
it in a bag before you even go in
because that you know the comedy club is
the place where you're supposed to
experiment and imagine if you were a
scientist and you were experimenting and
things were blowing up in your face you
wouldn't want that out there all the
time man you know Albert Einstein didn't
want all his formulas out there while he
was trying to figure them out so I'm
glad to hear that about Sandler I will
check out the the the special when I
have a chance and and I do hope you guys
will come check out the the stand-up
that I'm doing so 28th in San Jose at
The Improv I'll be in that the The
Improv in Irvine California in January
and we're booking out a bunch of other
stuff so yeah there you go
love the Norway Q&A I just posted on the
channel I think yesterday the Q&A from
Oslo Norway me asking Jordan questions
it's the only public thing that we've
posted from the entire tour so if you
haven't seen it do check it out so thank
you for that just so that Jordan
Peterson is coming to Auckland New
Zealand will you be accompanying him I
hope so so that's right after Australia
I had something I have to do that week
in the States so I don't think I can
unfortunately I'm sorry believe me I
would absolutely love to go to New
Zealand for a million reasons of course
I've got to try your lamb I get New
Zealand lamb here but like and that's
just one of the many reasons that I
would love to go there and I get a lot
of email from New Zealand also so don't
count me out just yet but unfortunately
I don't think it's gonna happen okay
let's see what's your least favorite
thing about touring with Peterson we
hear so much about how awesome it is I'm
curious if there's anything that bothers
you at all wow that's a question um no
there really isn't
you know the travel can be a little bit
exhausting at times like I'm actually a
little beat right now the reason I'm
wearing a hat is I didn't even shower
today because it's been so busy doing
patreon Hangouts today and you know I
got back and I immediately went to the
stand-up gig and then this other
stand-up gig and I interviewed Brett
Weinstein yesterday which will be on our
channel tomorrow and I had so much
business to catch up on and amira who's
been our director for three plus years
who's been just an absolute all-star at
every level
she actually accepted a new job has
moved on so we now the a part-time well
a part-timer taken her job which is
clearly a full-time job it's many
people's full-time jobs as we're hiring
for that and I know a whole bunch of
submitted resumes and we're trying to
figure all that out so there's just so
much going on so I would say the only
thing that's a little sucky is that I
feel like I'm a little bit behind on
things and actually one other thing
related to the show which I mentioned in
a live stream last week the one thing
that I think has suffered on the show is
that I haven't been able to do direct
messages because we've been taping a lot
of stuff in advance while I'm on the
road I did do two live streams last week
you know this is live stream right now
and I'm gonna try to do more of these so
that I can keep that connection with you
guys and so that I can I can speak
directly to you and you guys can ask and
and comment directly to me but I do miss
the direct messages I mean I think
that's where I can give you my most
clear cogent thoughts because I write it
out and I go directly to camera over
there and do it so I miss that a little
bit but we'll get back to that kind of
stuff and I also want to change what
and how we're doing it as the years go
by and always remain fresh and all that
good stuff but in terms of the tour
itself nothing bad
nothing bad Jordan and I have hit a nice
rhythm together I think we're really
bringing out the best in each other I
honestly feel like a better person than
I was like five months ago like if you
guys think Jordan has affected you and
if you think you've tried to incorporate
the 12 rules life to your life to fix
yourself it's like try being on the road
with the guy for six months and try
doing Q&A is where we need 45 minutes
together in front of 2,000 people and
he's talking to them but then he'll turn
and you know we're this close right and
it's like there's powerful stuff there
and that's been that's been very
exciting so it's all good it's very it's
very cool like there hasn't been one I
was actually the running joke with our
tour manager John who's also been
wonderful it's like this guy's like this
is the easiest tour ever he's like
nobody's doing drugs nobody's drinking
nobody's ripping up hotel rooms
he's like the two of you you know you
have dinner maybe or you shoot the [ __ ]
after you drink some you know sparkling
water and then talk about philosophy
he's like this is the easiest thing ever
the only screw-up of the entire tour is
I think when we were in where the hell
were we were in like Ontario Canada and
I said that we were in Toronto or
something like that which is like that's
like Tour screw-up 101 so yeah it's
really it truly has been great it really
has
Dave many of us are such huge fan of
yours would you ever consider a patreon
reward where you would follow some of
your fans on Twitter that's actually
kind of interesting you know I wouldn't
want to make it about like that feels
like it would almost be like bribery or
something um you know the Twitter feeds
have just become such a mess let me let
me think about that one actually because
I suspect do that if if you're a fan of
mine and and you enjoy what we do here
you probably treat Twitter with the same
sort of respect that I do so it probably
wouldn't be such a bad idea let me think
that one through I think there might be
something there um how much worse do you
think YouTube Facebook and Google have
to become before someone who creates a
competing service refuses to sell and we
start to shift over I mean look this is
the million dollar question right like
we've been talking about this for months
if you didn't watch my livestream with
Eric Weinstein from
six weeks ago or so we got into a little
bit there's no doubt that the
billionaire class is now paying
attention to this there is a billionaire
that I had on the show not too long ago
who knows what he's thinking about all
this stuff I can't tell you everything
at the moment but yes I think perhaps
finally we've hit critical mass with
this we're just today I tweeted out that
I just don't see people's tweets anymore
especially the IDW crew I never see
Eric's tweets or Brett's tweets or Sam's
tweets maybe I see Jordans every now and
again christina hoff sommers I never see
ion I never see a slew of them I never
see them what I do see often is I see
the conservative commentators that I
follow like a Bill Kristol or noah
rothman a couple guys like that I see
their tweets all the time but I never
see my other guys tweets now we know
that there's some level of shadow
banning going on there's something being
manipulated in the algorithm who the
hell knows and again these companies can
do whatever the hell they want people
just want some transparency so yes at
some point will something come in and
replace them yes I do believe that
hopefully I'll be part of something that
does do it and it's so funny it's like
man all you guys have to do it's sort of
like what I what I generally say about
the left at the moment which is all you
guys had to do these last couple years
was not be absolutely terrible like you
could have been basically terrible you
know like you could have just been
generically terrible and a lot of
liberals and lefties would have kind of
stayed with you because they would have
been like the right still is too scary
for me or something like that
more the societal pressure is to not
move politically or whatever you know or
the the cries of racism and bigotry
wouldn't have stopped people from moving
but instead they decided to be really
awful and I kind of feel like that's
what's happening with the tech companies
right now it's like we don't know if
videos get out to feeds anymore I don't
know how many of you actually are
watching this live at the moment and did
this get out - you know we've almost
900,000 subscribers how many people
actually got this notification people
tell me they get on subscribed all the
time
all of this stuff it's like there's got
to be a better way to do this to
communicate information there's such a
starvation for for good conversation and
enlightening thought and
not belittling and berating everybody so
I think it's coming together fear not
let's see I'd love to see a radical
feminist or sjw on the show how hard is
it to get one to accept an invitation
look I think you guys know this I am
happy to talk to anybody that will have
a decent respectful conversation if
there is there's a small crew of people
out there that are always attacking me
and mocking me and lying and slandering
me and all these things and then
demanding to come on the show and it's
like no I wouldn't want you in my life I
wouldn't want you in my home much less
my show but if there's someone out there
from that line of thinking that will
honestly defend their ideas and sit
across from somebody and not call you a
Nazi or a racist I'll be happy to do
that
you know I tweet out this list of
lefties all the time that I would love
to have on from you know Michael Moore
and Rob Reiner and Chelsea Handler and
Sarah Silverman and obviously Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and and a
whole slew of other people so I'd be
happy to do it but they have to discuss
things honestly and fairly you know what
give me one second because my dog wants
to get out of the studio and she's
giving me the look hold on one second
sorry that was that was six seconds she
gets she's 14 years old she gets
upstairs a little slower these days okay
let's see will you come to Cincinnati
bring Peterson please actually Peterson
did an event in Cincinnati but I was not
there I had to go home for uh where was
I going I think for a wedding so I
missed that but I'd love to go back
there night yeah I've actually never
been to Cincinnati so I would absolutely
love to go one of the funny things in my
in my crazy travels over the last couple
weeks was that in the midst of the whole
European thing Bob Saget who's uh you
got you guys all know about sag a
comedian from full house fuller house
America's Home Videos and a gajillion
other things that a legendary stand-up
I've become good friends with him and
his fiancee at time Kelly Rizzo who's a
great girl
and we they were getting married and I
left the UK I flew home for one day went
to the wedding and then flew back to
Amsterdam in the middle of the whole
thing but the wedding was was absolutely
great and at a great time and they're
just great and it's like you know when
you're in the thick of things it's like
I just didn't want to like do this and
work this hard and then like just miss
important things too so just doing my
thing okay let's see hey Dave a little
worried when Jordan told the Pug story
in one of your recent lectures so if you
guys haven't seen this this was Jordan
was referring to the count Danielle a
pug who made the Nazi salute and you can
watch this in our interview and from
Norway just a couple days ago there are
single lines out of that that the left
could use to further create an alt right
agenda I think you'd understand the
lines that could be edited out or
combined with his and the audience
laughter any concerns I'm not concerned
about it even though I think we made one
or two jokes about that look here's the
deal
we cannot look you know Jordans not
racist
okay the audience knows Jordans not
racist now could these people
selectively edit these videos could they
do this to literally any of us at any
time do they do it to me now yes I see
people these these awful Twitter anime
avatars who will quote me on things and
they will literally cut out the previous
sentence where I said I do not think or
no this is not right
can people do all of these things all
the time yes they can and we just live
in that time right now and I think the
best thing you can do is what we do here
which is we do not edit for content and
we and what I mean by that is we don't
edit for content in that if my guest
says something that is stupid or
ridiculous or whatever it is we let that
stand we do not edit for content the
only thing we edit for occasionally does
someone like has a sneezing fit or a
coughing fit or if a light blinks or
something like that like maybe we would
do it an edit around that but we do not
edit for content we've only edited for
content one time and the hundreds of
interviews I've ever done I don't want
to throw the guests under the bus but it
was somebody that really was not in good
shape for the interview and it was it
was just a train wreck and we I didn't
want to do it but ultimately my my team
convinced me that that's what we should
do just to save this person's a lot of
anguish let's just leave it at that but
in terms of that look Jordan was mocking
he was making the point that you have to
be free to express yourself you have to
be free to make jokes and I think he
could have even taken it a step further
that even if count Acula was racist
which Jordan is explicitly saying he's
not racist but you're still allowed to
do that and I would all I would argue
that you're still allowed to do that now
we have a stronger defense of free
speech here in the United States with
our First Amendment than they do in
Europe and and further he talked in that
QA about some of the things that are
happening in the UK right now
particularly around speech and you've
got the Yorkshire for Yorkshire Police
literally tweeting out saying you know
watch out for hate speech from your
neighbors and report them I mean this is
this is dangerous totalitarian stuff
that's spreading all over Europe right
now and we have to be very careful about
this so I get what you're saying that
someone could isolate one of that and
then the audience laughed when he said
this but his intention his intention was
not oh let's make fun of what the Nazis
did the intention is make fun of the
Nazis maybe you know flip all of these
things on their head and I think that
you know I think I said this to him in
that interview but you know comedy I
think it's Mel Brooks that said comedy
is tragedy plus time and you have to be
able to look back and make funny of
these things and I think partly partly
as long as you know we're talking about
this in the context of Nazis that's why
there's a lot of Jewish comics because
there's a lot of tragedy in the in the
story of the Jews and it's like all
right well you could either be dead or
you can learn to understand your history
and what happened and make fun of it to
sort of own it again and I think that
that's that's just one way of coping and
that's and if we don't have comedy I
don't know what we have yeah let's see
have you ever heard the song politically
correct by sr-71 it's great 20 years
ahead of its time it read the social
trajectory and speaks uncannily to what
is going on right now I haven't heard it
but I will keep this question up here
guys don't delete that one so that I can
check it out later
let's see Jordan Peterson is often
mentioned that the left is essential and
important to stem porch potential
tyranny of hierarchies of competence I'm
wondering do you think that Jordans
audience can acknowledge this is
important too this is a great question
Jordan has such nuanced and
compassionate perspective I'm curious if
the audience with his audience resonates
with this nuance or are they more
attracted to the critique of roasting
the left it's a difficult question to
answer I guess but interested in your
thoughts in perspective
you might win best question of the day
because that's that's seriously good
okay so in essence what you're saying
there is when Jordan critiques the left
which is which is sort of the red meat
for the audience is that what they're
really into or is it when he does this
more nuanced thing which is that we need
a healthy left the way we need a healthy
right because as he would say they cause
a tension between each other and that
tension is is sort of where a society
should live so that it doesn't tilt one
way too much or tilt the other way too
much yes I think they really really are
into that the red he doesn't do things
for applause lines like you know that he
doesn't do just the easy things like get
up there and be like the left don't bet
on feminism he never does that he never
does that
as a matter of fact one of the things
that I'll say to him sometimes is you
know sometimes he'll get a big laugh on
something and I can sometimes it's
intentional sometimes it's not
intentional but he always will talk
right through it because his intention
up there is not to get last then when I
go up there then I then my intention is
to get laughs and mess with him and have
fun with the crowd but his intention is
not for the audience reaction his
intention is truly to expand what his
thinking is and I watch this guy doing
it every night it's pretty freaking
awesome um so as to your question one of
the way he describes this is that you
need this healthy left and right the way
you would want a relationship in a
marriage you wouldn't want to beat your
wife in an argument let's say because
then you're the winner and she's the
loser and then you're married to a loser
what you would want is that you could
prove a point so and then sort of offer
a handout and say we can fix this
together and you would hope that that's
the way the other side will treat you as
well I sense that a lot of people are
to that nuance I mean I think that's
sort of what's happening with the IDW
it's right we're not just saying look
we're all frustrated with the left most
of us come from the left some of us like
Brett and Eric and Sam still still
believe they believe they're on the left
I can't honestly say that anymore
I see a much healthier center right
these days I see a much more interesting
and rich and politically diverse group
of libertarians and conservatives these
days and and former liberals or
classical liberals or former
progressives that are making a really
wide tent and that are really interested
in discussing ideas that's what I see
and I'm very comfortable with them well
I'd be glad to talk to those people on
their side of course but basically that
you need these two healthy sides that
have new ones that have tension with
each other because otherwise if you
break this thing and you've got one sort
of tyrannical side and guess what for
look I know that you know most of you
guys watching this right now you're out
you're other classical liberals
generally or you're libertarians or
conservatives but you don't want a wing
to the point that there's no opposition
because that opposition is what is the
sort of Gestalt of what a healthy
society is is made up of so I do think
people are in on it for the nuanced and
and he's given it to him he really is
he's not doing the red meat stuff let's
see do you ever fear of the IDW being
hijacked example you can all have
conversations but now what do you have
conversations about can the tolerance go
too far a good question and there's a
little bit of a follow-up Dave I just
want to tell you that you were awesome
in Brea this week and it was great to
meet you oh this is a different question
all right I'll get to that one in a
second so do you ever a fear of the IDW
being hijacked look it's it's tough
because what are we exactly like you
know are we probably a political
movement I think there's probably some
legitimacy to that but we're not a
political party are we a publishing
company are we a road touring group are
we a podcast network are we a YouTube
replacement are we all of these things
are we a news network
I mean who nobody really knows I promise
you were having a lot of discussions
about this but in terms of being
hijacked look I could see some I see
some times now mainstream trying to
hijack some of these IP
but I don't think you can fake it we
have we have been in the primordial stew
with you guys for years doing this and I
don't think you can fake it and the
things that we see and believe and talk
about are real and authentic and these
people I promise you guys these people I
look I've done plenty of TV shows almost
every one that you see on a generic TV
show they are that on television and
there's something else in real life and
you can even see it when the cameras go
on something changes in them and they're
a different person
these this crew it's not it is it is the
real deal and maybe look maybe it could
be maybe it could be hijacked in some
way that you know who knows maybe
tomorrow like CNN announces they have a
show with their big thinkers and maybe
they grab one of the IDW people and
throw a lot of money at them and
whatever I'm just not that worried and
it's almost like I just look I'm just
doing what I think is right and I'm
gonna keep doing it and I think we can
fix some of this stuff and I think we
are fixing some of this stuff so so
that's it right there
Dave just want to tell you that you were
awesome in Brea this week and it was
great to meet you I've brought three
friends with me and we all had a blast
the Weinstein brothers were great also
will probably come in again in January
to mine and bring a few others keep it
up it's not a question but I appreciate
it yeah I think we're really doing
something different and I'm so it's
awesome like when I meet you guys after
and especially when I meet the patreon
people it's like you guys are supporting
what I do and I we showed you guys a
great time and you just laugh and it's
not that serious and we make fun of all
of this nonsense and I'm a little bit
different you know look it's like when I
do these live streams with you I'm a
little bit different than Dave doing the
interview and I assure you when I'm
doing comedy I'm a little bit different
than Dave doing this right now it's just
like a different it's like a different
frequency that I'm operating at so I'm
glad you came and thank you for coming
and for those of you just tuning in I
will be at the San Jose improv on
November 28th and there will be at least
one IDW member coming let's see hey Dave
how is it that you were the one who
ended up being attached to Peterson and
his tours
fYI my podcast partner and I made it to
one of the shows in Seattle months back
and of course
every second of it keep up the
inspirationally profound work so the way
this whole thing started was you may
remember last January I had Shapiro and
Peterson in studio and by the way I'm
doing a live stream with Peterson and
Shapiro again and we're gonna cover all
new ground on November 30th so keep that
in your in your pocket on your calendar
but anyway I had them in studio last
January and that night
Jordan was doing his first ever theater
show the book had just come out and they
were just kind of testing it like could
he sell out a theater and what would it
be like and all that and as he was
walking out the door I said ma Jordan
you want me to open for you tonight I'll
warm up the crowd see what happens and
he was like yeah Dave come on down I
don't know what kind of Peterson
impression that was but anyway he said
come on down anyway we do the show it's
at the Orpheum here in LA downtown it's
about 2,000 people and I just did a
bunch of jokes about Jordan and about
lobsters and all of these things and the
crowd just absolutely ate it up and then
we did a Q&A after so basically I I do
stand-up Jordan does an hour and a half
or so and then we do some Q&A together
for another 45 minutes and Jordan's
agents were there and they immediately
were like whoa we got to do something
with this and I signed with them like
two or three days later maybe a week
later and then we decided to do this
tour and I gotta tell you it's it's uh
it's freaking fantastic it really is um
let's see have you invited Barry Weiss
on the Rubin report she would be
interesting I have invited her many
times she has said she's gonna do it we
haven't been able to coordinate the
thing in LA partly because of my travels
I think partly because of hers but we
will make that happen at some point what
do you think of attempting to brand
these folks that are attacking free
speech as liberals in particular in
particular using that word whenever
referring that to them in order to
distinguish between them and classical
liberals that many of ourselves consider
us to be that's interesting so that's
like saying it's a little bit of a sort
of regressive left thing like these
people are not progressive for progress
because being for progress would mean
that you're for equality for everybody
not equity or for equality of
opportunity for everybody these people
are regressive they want us to
regress they want us to go backwards and
start looking at people based on their
immutable characteristics their
sexuality and gender and and skin color
and the rest of it and that is not
progressive that is regressive so
illiberal it's good right I mean I've
heard I've obviously heard the word
before it's good because they are not
liberal liberal in us in its essence
means live-and-let-live it means you
believe in the individual you believe in
individual rights you believe in a light
touch of the government this is the
reverse of what progressives are who
believe in the collective and they
believe that the government has all the
answers they believe that the government
gives you rights I don't believe that
the government gives you rights I
believe you person watching this right
now you are born free you are born free
the government can protect your rights
and it can take your rights away but it
did not give you those rights it is your
human right this is where someone on the
more conservative side if I had Shapiro
or Prague or one of those guys they
would say these are god-given rights I
would say they are they are rights by
either by the the fact that you are
human makes you free you are born for
human it doesn't matter if it's
god-given or not you are free and
someone can take that away and lock you
up but they did not give you your
freedom no man gave you your freedom you
are free and they don't they don't
believe that they believe that the
government gave you those things so I
like I like the word illiberal you know
it's like one of those things it's like
look I had those two years when this was
all bursting forth originally where I
said regressive left all the time
because so many people realized there
was something wrong with the left and
the imagined wise came up with the
phrase regressive left and it's so
captured it was an easy way of
explaining to people what this segment
of the left was now I would argue that
segment of the left has now almost
encompassed the entire woke left it's
almost everything media and political
establishment and the whole thing but I
don't say regressive left anymore
it sort of was becoming a little
redundant and a bit meaningful and and
and I didn't want it to be a pejorative
I wanted it to be something that
identified something I think we've
really did that we really did do that
and not only do we do that but I but I
really proud to say that people talk
about classical liberalism now and I
think I was one of the people if not the
really the first person in this space
that got people starting to talk about
that again and then of course I did that
Prager you video why I left the left and
I and that thing I think it's their
number one video of all time and I think
it woke up a lot of people so you know I
wouldn't want to use any of these
phrases as pejorative to just mock but
if it's if it's a phrase if you say if
someone if you're in an argument with
somebody and they're telling you they're
a liberal but therefore all these a
liberal policies you say you know you're
not a liberal you're a liberal and
here's why well then I think that's
pretty effective let's see
for God's sakes how can we get Eric
Weinstein to post more on his YouTube
channel for posts in eight months there
are squirrels with more posts what can
you do to fix this I will well I spent
the last two days with him doing
stand-up and some other stuff I'm sure
I'll see him in the next couple of days
I will tell him this and he will not out
be outdone by a squirrel I assure you of
that much all right we got about 20
minutes left guys um let's see
[Music]
do you enjoy studying science that's
outside of politics learning for
learnings sake alright so let me deal
with the second part I like learning for
learnings sake you know well I think one
of the coolest things if I've done
anything right in this world is that I
get to learn every week so I just
yesterday interviewed Brett Weinstein
which were posting next week and this
guy is a wickedly brilliant evolutionary
biologist and he was put on the map
obviously because of what happened at
Evergreen and he and his wife no longer
have jobs and have had to move out of
the town that they love and I don't want
to give too much away of where they're
at now because you'll see it in the
interview next week but we did sort of
half the interview on what happened to
him and what his future is but then the
other half and we did about an hour and
a half together on on evolutionary
biology and explanations of all of the
things that are seemingly out of whack
these days and this recent talk that he
had with Richard Dawkins and what they
think how where they think that
evolutionary biology Fred thinks they
forked at a certain point and what he
thinks Dawkins gets wrong
what Dawkins gets right I mean the fact
that I get to sit with these people or
get to tour with Petersen or get to you
know listen to Eric Weinstein talk about
mathematics or whoever it is it's like I
learn every week so in a way that is
learned look it's learning for learnings
sake I happen to be doing it on a show I
happen to be doing it on something that
now has become a small production
company and that that is a profitable
business that I'm super proud of that
it's allowed me to buy a home and build
a studio here and all of these things
and we're completely fan funded which is
freaking amazing but I do consider most
of it learning for learnings sake if
that's possible it's like it's really
cool like I get to be around really cool
people and not only that but then when I
go out and I do these public events and
then I meet you guys
people people give me books and they
write these incredible letters and all
of these things and it's like we're
doing something guys let's let's keep
doing it and what we need more of you
guys to do is share these videos is
tweet about these things as gay get your
friends and families to know these ideas
because that's how we really can change
these things and and I think we're
actually doing it
do you have a fear that as tech
companies veer left do you think things
will progress beyond shadow banding and
deep platforming to outright hostile
advocacy against competing views I mean
this is sort of like the question of
like how much worse is it gonna get
before it gets better
and yeah I mean it seems that at you
know look they can be platform they can
screw with algorithms they can get rid
of likes they can get rid of follower
accounts they can do all of these
manipulations but it's like what are the
next hostile moves and what I would say
here is it's like forget what you think
I've said this before but it's like Alex
Jones as an example it's like look you
may think the guy's views are all
horrible he has said some horrible
things about Sandy Hook and a bunch of
other things it's like there are plenty
of horrible people out there go look at
Louis Farrakhan's Twitter and tell me
that what he's saying on any given day
in the videos that he's posting aren't
probably worse than what Jones was
saying every day or that Hamas who is
just committed to the destruction of all
Jews on earth has a Twitter account so
those guys are allowed on there
but Jones can't be on Facebook or on on
YouTube or on any of these things again
I mean it's so boring to make this about
jokes I'm not even talking about him
specifically but it's like look if they
can take out one person they can take
out anybody and the peep the type of
people who want to take people out are
not people who ultimately believe in
freedom and again this is not a defense
of Jones but it's like of Jones
specifically but it's like if the type
of people that do this it's not like
they take one person out and then
they're suddenly like no we're good to
go we want to get dinner no it's like oh
we moved the line and how can we move
that line a little bit further and then
you see what happened to bench pure the
last couple days I think it was Ohio
State he goes there and these people are
chanting that he's a Nazi in this
ridiculous [ __ ] and he's an Orthodox
Jew and they're calling him a Nazi and
then there's this great video by this
guy I think his name is Joe freckie
where he's interviewing these kids that
are protesting shibir and he gets the
mic in there but well what don't you
like about Ventura and they don't even
know any of his views and it's like it's
become this this leftist monster and I
monsters the only word that makes sense
to me around it has become an infection
in young people's minds unfortunately
where they're protesting they don't even
know why they're protesting they're
protesting because they believe that
victimhood but it's not even just victim
like that perceived victimhood is virtue
and it is not virtue guys what is virtue
every movie that you love think of your
favorite movie right now think of the
great adventure movies of all time Luke
Skywalker didn't look for someone else
to blow up the Death Star he went ahead
and did it you know it I mean Frodo
didn't be like oh where's the ring what
ring
could somebody take this ring and get it
to Mordor and drop it in the thing for
me no he did it he didn't just sit there
as the victim he is everything kneel
what a neo do you know a neo did all of
these guys every movie it's like you
everyone comes from something and some
of us come from Chitty or things and
some of us were born with more and some
of us were born less and some of us got
a limp and some of us are this color
that color and this sexuality immaculate
none of it matters get you've got you're
free if you live in a Western society
you're free and if you're afraid to say
what you think in a Western society and
we were in a bunch of countries in
Europe and Sweden in particular where
people are really afraid to say what
they think well do you think that your
silence is gonna somehow make it better
no there are plenty of bad people who
will take your silence and and only use
it to make more people be silent so you
better fight for what you believe in I
don't think I'm anyone special other
than for some reason I feel like I can
talk about this stuff and it hasn't
stopped me yet and you know what
yeah it's shitty when when these awful
journalists and they're not journalists
they're they're they're well as Candice
almond says their hit men you know and
they they're activists those what they
really are they're masking rating
masking and masquerading as journalists
yeah it's not fun having them write
these things about you and I know none
of you would ever want that and I don't
like it when it happens to me but you
know what we're all still here
Peterson's still here everybody's still
here that's been through this this thing
and you'd be through it too but everyone
has to think about their own life how
they will and responsibly hopefully and
seriously but as Douglas Murray said you
know when you get in the pool you might
find out that the waters not that cold
and I think that that is it everyone's
afraid of jumping in but if you actually
just put your foot in you might find
that it's actually more okay here and
you might find that yeah you're gonna
lose some friends but you're gonna make
better friends and you might find that
you feel better you physically feel
better because you're being more honest
with yourself and a slew of other things
so get out there and fight for what you
believe in even if you believe in things
that I don't believe I would be all for
you doing that how do we begin to
translate the important message
concerning individual liberty that you
and Jordan are doing to politics
individual liberty is not represented on
the tree on the traditional left-right
political scale yeah well there hasn't
been a great there hasn't been a great
let's say stance for the individual in a
long time like Rand Paul talks about the
individual because he's basically a
libertarian
what's his name Paul Ryan would talk
about the individual quite a bit and I
know he was really influenced by Ayn
Rand
but there isn't a real fighter for the
individual the way that there should be
you know as more and more of the left
goes to the identity politics thing and
as the Democrats won just
weeks ago there they've realized all
right well this maybe is a winning
strategy now so they're gonna only go in
on it more which is why I wanted them to
lose I wanted them to lose because I
thought all right if they lose maybe
then the more extreme set of democrats
the democratic socialists would be
washed away and then some decent
liberals that used to exist would would
magically appear again maybe a JFK could
appear again and then that that could
actually be a decent democratic party
against something that I could probably
be part of again etc etc but there is no
as they've done that the Republicans
haven't done a great job or the
Conservatives or whatever on the right
have not done a great job of really
explaining why the individual is the
root of a free society and that one
should only care about individual rights
and we shouldn't be giving to this group
and taking from that group and things of
that nature this is a winnable argument
because it's a clear clean argument and
it's the most human argument there is
because everyone watching this everyone
listening to this you me everybody we
would only want to be judged as
individuals none of us are sitting or no
one's sitting there if you're watching
this in your black you're not sitting
there going I wish I could be judged the
way all other black people are judged
there are good black people there are
bad black people they're good Jews bad
Jews nice Muslims mean Muslims and think
you know great gay people awful gay
people everything is out there and so
that's why when these people say I'm
full women so mark hamill who is Luke
Skywalker you guys know my feelings on
Star Wars he tweeted out this thing the
other day about this that we should have
all women in politics but he doesn't
really mean that because you don't mean
you want nikki Haley and Sarah Sanders
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and Republican
women you mean you want women who behave
as you want them to behave and that's
the this the silliness and the
foolishness and the lazy thinking of
collectivism is that you can't if I'm
for gay people really are you for
Republican gay people are you for gay
people who are into firearms and who
happen to be pro-life no you're not into
those gay people so to say you're for
gay people is actually that's actually
sort of offensive say you're for certain
things and certain individuals happen to
be for those things but I'm for women
and then the new thing is that if your
there was this real push after the
election from left against white women
and the women's March was teaching we're
gonna have to teach white women and it's
like oh really do we just have to bow to
you forever because we have different
political thoughts ah it's gross it's
actually it's gross and racist guys um
let's see here we got about nine minutes
left I want to get to as many as
possible I would love to have you
interview some of the climate change
scientists who challenged MSM mainstream
media narrative have you talked to mark
Stein about that you know we were in
touch with mark Stein for a while and I
did gutfeld shows with him once about a
year ago and then it just kind of fell
apart so I don't know where that left
off but I'll ask my guys after this and
I'm sure we can make that happen um
let's see do you think the increase in
California fires could be partly caused
by the numerous red tape regulations to
protect to protect trees from humans I
don't know enough about this I mean I
feel like this is a slightly troubling
question perhaps we don't know exactly
what caused these fires yet from what I
understand I think one of them maybe was
a campfire look little of this is just
nature nature does things now also we've
been in a crazy drought here in LA so I
moved to LA in February of 2013 so it's
not even that it's just about six years
if I tell you guys that in in six years
I don't think I'm exaggerating when I
would say we've had twenty days of rain
like real rainy days we've had you know
some drizzle here and there there was a
couple years ago we had like four days
in a row where it really rained but I
don't know that we've had more than 20
days of bringing ballparking it
basically I mean we're in a pretty drop
pretty dry time we're in a drought and
you know when you drive through the
hills here in Los Angeles there are
times when when it's rained a little bit
and everything's green and then there's
times when everything is just dry and
it's like man you could set fire to
everything just like that and then you
know there's so many houses in these odd
crevices and hills and then the way the
Santa Ana winds blow where once the fire
starts it blows it on to I mean it's
literally blowing embers over there this
is when they talk about John
iwase I don't know enough about it
specifically related to regulations and
everything else but I don't think
everything can just be solved by
government regulations obviously and I
don't think everything can be solved I
think nature is pretty freakin powerful
so yeah that's that that's my thought on
that California seems to be past the
point of no return what do you think
would have to happen for a peaceful
political remedy to the left this
bottomless pit the state is in I don't
know it's weird I mean look we have
super high taxes here I don't know that
we get a ton for them you know our mayor
or our governor now Gavin Newsom is as
far left as you can get he was the mayor
of San Francisco San Francisco is kind
of gross they have literally have an app
that tells you where human poop is so
you don't step in it the last time I was
in Berkeley our car got broken into on a
nice Street and they stole my bag when
my sister-in-law's or when my
brother-in-law's parents were visiting
from out of the country visiting
Berkeley about a month ago they got
mugged in broad daylight they literally
tore his mom's rings off her finger
broad daylight so and I can't look we go
to Seattle when I've been now that I've
toured the whole country when I would go
to the cities that are more progressive
those are the cities where there are
more drugs and more crime and more
homeless people it just is that is just
a fact when I've gone to the cities that
are more conservative Salt Lake City
Dallas things like that they're
beautiful they're clean it seems like
the economies are strong there you don't
see as many homeless people I mean it
all adds up to something doesn't it so
what can happen in California I don't
know I do know that there is a growing
conservative libertarian movement here
in California I don't know that it's
really getting a lot of momentum but
when I had John Kasich on who's the
governor of Ohio who ran for president
obviously he was meeting with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and a bunch of other
people and look armed Schwarzenegger was
the governor believe it or not of
California not too long ago and he was a
Republican so you know these things have
been flow but I do think it's possible
that eventually you know California will
tax out all the good people who will
just leave and they'll move to Florida
and they'll move to ours
New Mexico and Utah and Colorado and and
then who knows what will be left here I
can also tell you this just from living
here there are way more homeless people
here now than there were when I moved
here I don't know what that exactly
means I don't know exactly how all of
those policies that have been put in by
by Democratic and Lefty politicians have
laid all of that out but you know we
shall see let's see you have an open
invitation to the weekly wake-up County
Libertarian Party meeting in Raleigh I
will keep that in mind thank you very
much
let's see Dave I keep seeing these new
laws regarding gender and sexuality and
morality how can people keep track of
what's legal and what's illegal anymore
things could be changing so fast well
I'd want to know exactly what laws
you're talking about specifically what I
will tell you these is is one of those
interesting things that happen to us
during the tour was that Jordan and I
both had sort of circled then sweeden as
sort of an interesting stop because for
us on my YouTube channel here the fifth
most watched country is Sweden which is
really interesting because there are not
a lot of people in Sweden I think
there's around 12 million people so it's
a pretty tiny country so US is number
one then its UK and then it's usually
Canada and Australia they they flip
between three and four and then Sweden
and you know I've had a couple Swedish
people on the show which i think is part
of it iron flam who's a very popular
comedian and I met him there he's a
great guy and I've had tea no Sun in
dodgy who's an economist who I had on
mostly talking about immigration these
are both a long time ago he knows a
couple years ago read anyway we both
sort of circled Sweden is because the
Jordan gets a lot of mail from there we
thought what's going on in Sweden so the
shows we do two shows in Sweden they
sold out like five minutes in each the
crowds were phenomenal like the endless
endless cheering they were so great my
need and greets after we're absolutely
packed it was just such an interesting
cool group people but the reason I bring
this up related to your question is I
thought that most people when we do the
Q&A we use this app called slide on
people submit questions and people can
both things and the majority is on stage
I go through the ones that I think are
the best and I pick interesting ones I
pick funny ones that the golf though all
ones I pick heartfelt ones personal
stories whatever it is and I thought
mostly we were gonna see things about
immigration in Sweden because they
definitely have an immigration problem
and there were a lot about immigration
but but the vast majority of questions
were gender related and theirs will have
to do a show on this and when I have
Jordan and studio will talk about this a
bit more but it's really really
interesting because the Swedes and the
Scandinavian countries in Nordic
countries in general I've done
egalitarianism really well that men and
women are equal and have been equal for
a long time
Sweden right now has a supposedly a
self-proclaimed feminist government many
women are equal completely and as this
has happened what they've realized is
that men and women are still different
despite equality that women are more
into people and men are more into things
so despite all of the equality that you
would want in a society that's what they
have in Sweden that there are still more
female nurses and there are still more
male engineers so it's like they ran the
experiment of equality we're gonna treat
everyone equally men and women can do
whatever they want everyone can live as
they wish and yet still there are there
are jobs locations that women want to do
and that men want to do and that just is
so it's like the social justice warriors
of Sweden which are now very embedded in
the government aren't letting the
experiment of humanity they did the
experiment how can we do it let's keep
make everyone exactly equal that's what
everyone should want well we did it and
now they've got the result they've got
the they did the experiment they got the
result but they won't let them have the
result cuz they don't like it because
there are still more women that are
nurses then and there's still more men
that are engineers so they want to
engineer a society so you'd end up
having people doing things that they
don't want to do so would it make more
would it be a better society if you had
50/50 or exact proportion male nurses
and female nurses and exact proportion
male engineers and female injuries I
mean does anyone think that would be a
better free or happier society no that
would very clearly be a worse tyrannical
authoritarian society so it's really
interesting stuff over there and I'll
talk to Jordan about it
and anyway I didn't get to everything
here but we'll keep some of these
catalogued and we'll get to them next
week or next month so yeah if you
haven't joined patreon.com slash rubin
report and if you join at level 1
I take all patreon questions here we
also do group chats which I was doing
all day small chat sometimes there's
three or four people in groups sometimes
there's fifteen or sixteen people and um
there's all sorts of other rewards you
can get free meet and greets to my
stand-up events and all that good stuff
I will be in San Jose at the improv on
November 28th you go to dave rubin comm
events I'll be at the Irvine improv in
January at the Orpheum here in LA on
December first with Jordan Jordan and
Ben in studio on November 29th I'll be
in Calgary and Vancouver first week of
December with Jordan what else Hawaii
with Jordan the day before Thanksgiving
I'm literally flying there that morning
and leaving that night which is bananas
but you know just do what you got to do
and what else I think I'm at the
University of Montana first week of
December also and a whole bunch and then
we're gonna be in San Diego and a whole
bunch other things in January whoo
that's a lot of talking alright thanks
everybody appreciate it remember it's
patreon.com/scishow Band report if you
want to get in on this and we are fan
funded and all that good stuff and I'm
not gonna talk for the rest of the day
all right good night everybody